hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about pathogen replication inside
macrophages first let's make sure that
you understand what macrophages are they
are cells that are part of the immune
system and they have a lot of very
important functions as part of the
immune system for example they're known
for phagocytosis I have another video on
the steps of phagocytosis if you want to
check that one out
phagocytosis is the the process shown
right here where a macrophage and gulfs
a bacterium and then ends up using a
organelle called a lysosome it's full of
basically digestive enzymes and driven
acidic compartment merges that with the
vesicle called the phagosome that
brought that bacterium in digests that
bacterium and then expels sort of the
leftovers at the end so this is one way
that the immune system can fight
pathogens so now can we just do this
they also produce cytokines and
chemokines these are basically just
chemicals that cause various immune
system cells to be activated or help
them to get from one place to another so
those are some pretty important
functions and then also macrophages do a
process called antigen presentation
which is where they take a few of the
leftover bits of a chewed-up microbe and
actually present them on the surface of
the cell to help activate other immune
system cells so very important and you
might be asking yourself if these
macrophages are so important to fighting
bacteria and clearing the body of an
infection why your pathogens replicating
inside them
that's a good question first let's talk
about what kind of pathogens can do this
there are some bacteria in particular
these are all intracellular bacteria
meaning that they're pathogens that
enter host cells and replicate inside
host cells instead of replicating
inside the body but outside of cells
those are the extracellular bacteria
these are intracellular bacteria and
some of them actually preferentially
replicate inside macrophages
preferentially is the key term here
because it's not just that they
replicate inside a cell but they prefer
to replicate inside macrophages versus
other types of cells which is maybe a
little counterintuitive some of the
bacteria that do this are things like
Listeria Salmonella micro bacterium
Legionella these cause things like food
poisoning and tuberculosis and
Legionnaires disease so some pretty
important pathogens and there are also
some viruses that replicate inside
macrophages these would include HIV and
influenza
although macrophages are not necessarily
their preferred cell to replicate in but
they certainly can do it so now let's
talk about the mechanisms how are they
replicating inside a macrophage and
there's a few different possibilities
one is this right here use of a
secretion system to manipulate cell
activities to create a favorable
compartment that just means using some
gene products some proteins that they
can make to manipulate cell activities
to alter this process to create a
favorable environment to replicate in so
for example some bacteria can actually
prevent this process right here from
happening so the lysosome and the
phagosome never merge and remember that
the lysis on this pool of digestive
enzymes and it's also a fairly acidic
compartment and so when it emerges those
those things break down the bacterium
but if the bacterium prevents this from
happening prevent the lysosome from
being able to merge with the phagosome
well then this bacterium can just
replicate inside the phagosome which is
a friendly place for it to do it if
there's no
system that can come along another
possible mechanism is use of either a
secretion system or a pore forming toxin
a toxin that's going to create some
pores and a membrane to escape from the
phagosome so that means that a bacterium
that does that would use a secretion
system or or performing toxins to poke
holes in the phagosome membrane so that
it can escape the phagosome and then
just replicate in the cytosol so that's
another possible mechanism for pathogen
replication inside a macrophage now we
still haven't talked about why why do
they want to do this right this is a
dangerous cell this is a cell that is
made to kill these pathogens to to
completely digest them and chew them up
and spit them out so why are they
preferring to do it well scientists have
a few ideas one is that well if they're
going to be phagocytosed anyway they
might as well evolve a way to deal with
that and what that means is these
macrophages are so good at recognizing
some of these pathogens especially
intracellular bacteria that it's likely
that if they get into the body but
they're going to wind up inside a
macrophage anyway and so evolutionarily
speaking if they're going to end up
inside a macrophage anyway it would make
sense that over many many generations
they would adapt ways to to deal with
that and to still be able to infect the
cell another possibilities that
macrophages are just easy to enter I
mean these pseudopods right here or
pseudopodia are these sort of feet like
projections almost like little fingers
that will engulf anything foreign it's
so easy to get inside but as long as the
pathogen can then find a way to divert
these activity
so that it can still replicate then you
know it's good to go so that's another
possibility another reason why it might
be beneficial to replicate inside
macrophages is that macrophages are
typically very long-lived they live a
long time in the body which gives a
stable replication niche for these
pathogens and also macrophages move
around a lot they are responsible for
traveling through the bloodstream to get
to different points of infection and so
since they're moving around the body so
much a pathogen that gets into a
macrophage kind of can ride the bus all
around the city as it were they can use
the macrophage to travel anywhere else
in the body and so scientists think that
these these three sort of reasons
explain why some of these bacteria want
to replicate inside a cell that is
otherwise designed to kill them and so I
think this is a really fascinating
subject if you're interested in some
other related subjects things like
binary fission and bacterial growth or
looking at the steps of phagocytosis in
more detail or other parts of the immune
system like antibody structure and
function and I've got videos on all of
those topics I encourage you to check
them out and thanks for watching today